in today's money watch we're talking
about donating the charity on this
giving Tuesday for the last 10 years the
global movement has inspired millions of
people to give back and celebrate
generosity last year 35 million people
participated in giving Tuesday and 2.7
billion dollars with the beat was
donated in the United States alone CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here with what you need to know about
those charitable donations and what they
could mean for your taxes Jill good
morning good to see you great to be here
all right so let's talk about it what do
taxpayers need to know about Charity
donations this year well first of all
during the covid era the cares act the
stimulus plan allowed people to give to
charity and get a tax benefit everybody
could give 300 bucks or 600 to charity
and get a little write-off that's gone
for this year but I want to be clear the
vast majority of people who give money
to charity today and every day they do
not give for a tax benefit they give
because they want they want to give
exactly right so that's the big change
for this year okay
in order to receive that tax benefit you
have to itemize your tax deduction right
how do you do that exactly what I was
thinking oh my God that's so good
so when we file our taxes there's two
ways to file one is to claim a standard
deduction and the other is to itemize
deductions itemized seems like such a
pain I know it is by the way only 10
percent of people itemized because the
threshold for standards because it's a
pain no because the threshold for for
the standard deduction is up and that
means it means that you get a certain
amount of money from the IRS to write
off every year so it's about 25 000 for
married couples almost thirteen thousand
for individuals if you add up your
charitable contributions your state and
local taxes your mortgage interest and
all those things add up to more than the
standard deduction than you do itemize
only people who itemize get a benefit on
their tax returns for giving so that's
important I just want to be clear about
that there's a lot of ways to give you
can give highly appreciated stocks maybe
your nana died 30 years ago and left you
some IBM you never did anything with it
if you itemize you might gift some
shares of a company to a charity but not
everyone can do that again only 10
percent of filers actually itemize and
that means only ten percent are getting
a big tax deduction from giving so
inevitably uh there will be stories
after this sadly tragically of people
who were scammed giving in to Charities
that they thought were legitimate so how
do people avoid that so the IRS has a
wonderful tool and it allows you to
search the name of a charity and see if
it is actually legitimate and so the
irs.gov website if you just look at the
charitable organization Search tool you
pop the name in you see if it's there
one other area that I think is important
a lot of people want to make sure the
money that I give goes to what I want to
give to not to a bloated infrastructure
and so if that's the case there are a
lot of different resources like charity
Alliance and the wise giving Alliance
and charity Navigator and these
organizations help you understand what
portion of your donation goes to the
program and what goes to overhead there
we go keeping it real with
you oh thank you so much we'll be right
back